eine frau die eigentlich den kindern
helfen soll sie retten soll soll sie nun
umgebracht haben es ist eigentlich
unvorstellbar wie wie kann man das
überhaupt erklären vor allem einer frau
man denkt dort meistens das genau die
babys und kindern gar nichts antun
könnten ja noch ist nicht ganz klar ob
sie die kinder wirklich getötet hat vor
allen dingen ist nicht klar wie genau
sie getötet hat und ob sie das ziel
hatte zu töten oder wie man es von so
genannten todesengel kennt dass sie fast
töten um sich danach als retter
aufspielen zu können diese informationen
wären aber wichtig um überhaupt etwas
zum motiv sagen zu können und auch die
polizei darum gebeten
gerade in diesem fall aus rücksicht vor
den trauernden eltern das mit vorsicht
anzufassen aber eine sache kann ich
definitiv sagen dieses phänomen dass
serienmörderin im krankenhaus agieren
ist keineswegs neu
das gab es schon öfter das ist auch
leider gar nicht so selten wie viele
leute glauben man sagt immer bei mord
ist die aufklärungsrate in deutschland
weit über 90 prozent und in den meisten
fällen sind die täter männer
man muss aber leider davon ausgehen dass
auch beim morden die dunkelziffer hoch
ist es gibt immer wieder diese zahl dass
nur die hälfte aller morde überhaupt
erkannt wird
jetzt könnte man sagen na ja aber wenn
jemand im park erstochen legt dann muss
man das doch erkennen dass kann nicht
unentdeckt bleiben
ja wenn jemand im park erstochen legt
aber jemand der friedlich im krankenhaus
einschläft gerade wenn man über ältere
personen spricht da kommt typischerweise
nicht die kripo und das sieht erstmal
als natürlicher tod aus das heißt ja es
gibt auch serien mörderinnen und gar
nicht mal so selten
sie unterscheiden sich aber von
serienmördern in vier wichtigen punkten
erstens sie wählen die leisen morton
ertrinken vergiften ersticken dinge die
von außen auch von den besten ermittler
oder profiler der welt keineswegs als
tötungsdelikte erkennbar sind und schon
gar nicht von hausärzten die nicht
unbedingt darin geschult sind die spuren
und die feinen details an tatorten zu
lesen gerade wenn sie die familie kennen
vertrauen haben oder gerade auch im
krankenhaus wird überhaupt nicht
großartig ermittelt oder geprüft sondern
gerade wenn wir nennen es beim namen
wenn ein 85 jahre alter mann friedlich
einschläft kommt nicht die kripo also
erstens serien mörderinnen wählen die
leisen morton vergiften
ersticken 2 sie töten an orten an den
toten nicht auffallen zu hause
pflegeheime hospize krankenhäuser
drittens sie töten personen zu denen sie
zugang haben mütter töten ihre kinder
ehefrauen töten ihre ehemänner
pflegerinnen töten ihre patienten
das heißt personen zu denen sie zugang
haben es gibt kein kidnapping es gibt
keine entführung und niemand würde
skeptisch werden wenn er eine
krankenschwester sieht die eine spritze
verabreicht selbst wenn jemand auf
frischer tat den mord sehen würde würde
man nicht mal die polizei rufen weil das
im krankenhaus einfach keine
ungewöhnliche situation ist und der
vierte punkt sie unternehmen oftmals
schritte es noch als natürliche tode zu
tarnen
das heißt sie denken sich eine
geschichte ein setting aus wie das alles
erklärbar ist und sie damit nichts zu
tun haben oder nichts ungewöhnlich ist
diese vier dinge in kombination die
leisen morton opfer zu dem sie zugang
haben an ordnern den toten nicht
auffallen und sie unternehmen
anstrengungen ist als natürliche tode zu
tarnen
das ist der grund warum die opferzahlen
oftmals hoch sind und warum
serienmörderin in vielen fällen nicht
auffallen mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dir das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren